so guys a tornado passed through our
County on April 12th
some of you were asleep Wow well I was
awake I got a notification on my phone
and I ran to the basement with my
housemates and it's interesting what
comes to mind when you're in crisis mode
so I'm there sitting in the basement
listening to the wind howl and
transformers falling and all these
things I'm in trees and I get this
thought if I were to die right here
right now who would take care of my
goldfish find out on this episode of LED
live hey you're watching LED live this
show where we use the light of Christ to
expose the darkness found in media and
our culture today if you're new here
welcome please consider subscribing and
hit the notification bell set it - also
you can receive all of our videos when
we post them every single week every
single Friday we're on the road to a
hundred thousand subscribers guys yes we
thank you those people those of you who
have been with us from the beginning and
helped us grow we really really do
appreciate you and we have some exciting
news we're working on an anime
documentary you guys want to tell us
about that
Mikey tell them a little bit so we get
comments every single week every week
about anime hey are you guys gonna do
anything about anime Dragon Ball Z
specifically a big time one and it's a
huge thing in our culture like people
are just obsessed with it it gets really
dark and so me and Scott I started
looking into it and we're shocked that
people are even having questions about
this stuff like should I be watching
this no it's interesting because you
know we've analyzed so many movies and
usually these things are kind of hidden
within it it's sort of like this imagery
that you kind of have to like know
you know the Bible says this and you can
kind of plug and play the characters but
in the anime world it's like everybody's
on Team Satan and they say it just like
that and it's just like there's no
hiding this at all so yeah you know I
was actually kind of shocked when we
were putting it together and the script
has really grown this might be like a
five-part series because this is like so
much you so much I mean literally you
could do whole projects on just one
anime but we got a chance to go downtown
and downtown Chattanooga to the new
VidCon I wasn't conned nuget cuz I
remember it was gonna Kanu get kinda
good and that's kind of like a comic-con
for for this local area and everybody we
interviewed it was amazing right they
all said I got into this as a kid I got
into this watching Cartoon Network and
literally Dragonball Z was like the
introduction to it so you know we're
kind of hoping that you know this will
give you the tools but also when you see
it in the light of the Bible it
definitely is a shocker yeah just just
to throw this out there there is a
really dark dark world of it including
pornographic and everything we're not
even touching that because that's
obvious we're touching on the most
popular animes and these are the ones
that are disturbing so it's awesome well
that's something you'd like to help us
with there are many different ways you
can do that you can consider becoming a
patron or you can donate through our
website or you can get one of the little
eye Studios t-shirts to where your
witness all of those links will be in
the description box below we've been
releasing documentaries the little s
Studios documentaries every single
Tuesday for daca Tuesdays at home and we
release it on YouTube for free every
10,000 views we leave it up for another
24 hours so if you've been seeing those
documentaries and this is a documentary
you want to get behind so we can get it
out to the masses please consider
contributing to this ministry so guys
did you have any basement thoughts on
April 12th when you were writing out the
tornado I'm glad my house made to walk
me out because I did not hear a thing
you hear anybody go at one point time I
walked actually outside of my we have a
storm shelter in my basement and so I
walked outside to go
something and the lightning was flashing
did you guys see any of that It was as
if somebody was taking a strobe shh-shh
that's what this guy was doing and
there's no sound
there was no boom it was just like
blinking and at the first I thought
somebody was like flipping on and off
switches or something but both my son
and I were passed out my daughter and my
wife were staying up watching all the
storm storm stuff and they were scaring
each other you were getting a strobe I
guess I was getting the sound because of
it like 1134 I just heard a bomb blow up
in my backyard like I never heard
anything like that before but yeah we
just had some branches in our yard oh I
live like an hour away from these guys
so you guys are in in the thick of it
for sure yeah and it only lasted for
about 15 minutes but the damage is
horrendous yeah watch you Keith
nothing not where I live there's I mean
not I think not a blade of grass in my
yard nothing wrong we have a basement
which is unusual for us like the whole
used to live in Missouri
the whole time I lived there I probably
should have lived in a place that had a
basement but we never did and you know
you get to the point in Missouri it's
like a tornado warning tornado watch I
mean you hear it so frequently and you
start to get like oh yeah there's
another tornado yeah I mean certainly we
experienced high winds but our
particular location I can't I don't even
remember the last time there was a
tornado that actually hit where we were
at in the surrounding area yes but not
where we were at so okay well this was
my first tornado for sure coming from
New York but um my aunt she has a
daughter-in-law who just moved to
Chattanooga from South America oh wow so
when she got the alert you know this is
her first time she don't really know
what to do and she got really scared
actually her son was terrified they live
in a high-rise apartment they don't have
like a nice lobby area or even a
basement to go to so in a panic they
were just trying to figure out what to
do what would you advise someone who is
living in a high-rise there's a tornado
coming what do you think that they
should do my my friend that moved out
here from paradise him and his family
they went through the whole fires
impaired
and you know that was traumatizing in
itself but then they just literally
moved here less than a year ago and they
were in an apartment building they had
two stories as well and they have
nowhere to go and so they hid underneath
the staircase and that was you know they
were all huddled in there in the closet
they could hear the trees scraping over
the roof and you know stuff blowing
around and I mean it's terrifying I've
heard that it's good I was gonna give an
example so let me let you go first maybe
a bathtubs are supposed to be good
places
yeah the heavier-duty ones and then what
else away from windows for sure don't go
anywhere near a window usually the only
thing that survives a tornado like this
is the toilet for an apartment complex
maybe go down to the washer the lowest
area possible well I want to guess what
she did in a panic she took herself and
her two kids and they climbed up in
their car and drove in the middle of her
tornado so her mother-in-law's house so
they could sleep in her basement
so my Mikey and I am we got a chance to
go into NC ground zero of where this
tornado was damaged and high water
across East Tennessee tonight after
strong storms ripped through the area
take a look at the destruction left
behind by that storm hundreds of people
in parts of Chattanooga and the
neighboring communities are now
displaced devastation as far as the eye
can see
National Weather Service meteorologists
say this is the aftermath of an f3
tornado that slammed into the East
Brainerd area of Chattanooga then moved
through Ottawa and Collegedale ef3
tornado 1500 yards wide travel for nine
miles by the time it was over more than
150 homes and businesses were destroyed
by early morning dispatch was
overwhelmed with more than 1300
emergency calls when people who say they
were trapped under there collapsed homes
Hamilton County emergency management
officials tell News 4 jacks the tornado
killed two people and sent 17 others to
the emergency room Red Cross is now
paying for 140 people to stay in hotel
rooms because the county is not allowed
to set up shelter due to coronavirus and
my brother has a ministry that kind of
travels around and helps out in natural
disasters and stuff and he had some some
of his ministry colleagues there helping
out with the disaster and this one guy
that we were helping he actually was in
his car when it went over and he had
just gotten home and he hadn't got out
of his car yet and then things just
progressed and got worse just out of
control and it took his car spun it
around and then rolled it on the ground
he said the whole time he was in his car
and it went right over the top of him
and he said trees and everything are
just like swirling around he'd never
been that scared see that is like the
worst place you could be trying to drive
around yeah stuff flying around but it's
crazy what we do or what we default to
when we're unprepared how would you
agree with that there are some crazy
things and unexpected situations but I
did have a second thought in my basement
I wasn't just thinking about my goldfish
but I thought to myself you know if I
were to die seriously right here right
now how would I be you remembered has
that thought ever come to you there's
that girl from Led laughs okay well this
is true so yes my soul salvation is
important and I know I'm I'm at peace
that I'm safe through race but really I
was thinking what will I be leaving
behind you know how will I be remembered
I I don't believe someone's impact
should die with the person right you're
doing something right if your memory
still inspires change so I'd like to
think that I have my whole life ahead of
me
you know I'm young but in the reality
that's not the case we can die at any
moment so there's a reason why Paul said
let no man despise thy youth be thou an
example of the believers in what in Word
in conversation in charity in spirit in
faith and in purity that's 1st Timothy
chapter verse 12
so everyone even the youth are
responsible for being a true example
what's an example
interesting I think with somebody like
observes what your life was engaged in
or you know I mean we're still we're
still reading about the lives that you
know people have that have written the
Bible and we're still learning from
their experience in their examples and
so I think if somebody can take a look
at like your life's work or you know it
could it could be that they're inspired
by you you were a great person at that
job and and you know other people see
how you've treated other people and say
hey you know that I would like to be
like that person you know and be loving
to everybody I don't know ya know you
hit the nail on the head being an
example means being like a pattern or a
guide that people can relate to or even
pattern their lives after it's like a
legacy of sorts when you think about it
they can be passed on from generation to
generation the dictionary definition of
legacy is an amount of money or property
left in someone left to someone in a
will so there are many things that I
want to attain land education contacts
finances money you guys relate to that
I'm sure building that up and these are
not things that are just beneficial for
me I want to leave them for my children
future children however the most
important legacy and I believe that's
what Paul is really getting the at is
not physical it's actually spiritual
it's a spiritual legacy and first
Timothy chapter 4 verse 12 when I read
it it's clear to me that age is not a
factor to determine one spiritual legacy
you can start as a youth but what does
what does that look like what does
leaving a spiritual legacy look like and
the ideas come to mind you know I think
if if your family knows you know what
what kind of a spiritual person you were
you know like I when I think of the
spiritual patriarch or matriarch in our
family I knew my grandparents and you
know my grandma was a little prayer
warrior just prayed for everybody and I
always thought that was just so neat I
mean every morning her list was so large
it took her an hour to get through just
praying for people
and and so I've always kind of thought
of that when I think of prayer warriors
from my understanding leaving a
spiritual legacy it's really living to
the highest biblical standard possible
and that's not something that's
complicated I didn't say it was easy but
it should definitely not be complicated
Jesus even summarized it in two points
you know and love one another exactly
and that's Matthew chapter 22 verses 36
to 40 so you would agree that we should
live our lives to the highest biblical
standard that's that's what can help us
develop our spiritual legacies often we
talk about people that just try to get
by like hmm you know tell me what I can
I can't watch her is this okay like I
just want to barely you know get by just
I don't know a picture like those
lukewarm Christians that Jesus sees in
the last days you know yeah so I'm
sitting there in my basement you know
listening to the wind I didn't see the
light flashes but I definitely heard the
thunder and I was like well pants I have
both you know can't I leave a physical
legacy as well as a spiritual and is it
possible for me to develop both of them
in my youth or will one suffer if I
dwell on the other there's this Bible
text that everyone loves to quote and it
has a beautiful promise right seek ye
first the kingdom of God and His
righteousness and all these things shall
be added unto you do you know where
that's taken from Matthew 6:33 yes but
what are these things I'm thinking like
you I always understand it as
necessities not necessarily everything
that you want but the things that you
need in life so it's like they would be
provided for you
yeah Jesus is talking to a group of
people I think then they were like well
you know if we if we do follow after you
if we do what you're saying what about
our families what about our own needs
what about when I go from place to place
am I gonna have everything that I need
so at least that's that's my takeaway I
don't look at it like
if I follow Jesus I am sitting and
living large I've got a friend his name
is London Lee I hope I can use his name
and he's just an awesome Bible worker
I've known him for years and just kind
of a real charismatic type personality
you know loves to educate and teach
people about the Bible and his family
just travels around and and and does
Bible work and just wherever they get to
they stay for a little while I mean he
really has no one single place and he
called me during during this whole Kovan
shutdown right and he's just like I
don't have a place what am I gonna do so
he just says god I know you've got this
can you provide something and all of a
sudden his friend called up and said hey
we've got this other house a vacation
house that they was in remember where he
said it was no I was in Minnesota on a
lake like out in the middle of nowhere
and he said it was just this most serene
beautiful place and they said you can
stay here what like this whole covin
things going down and he's destroyeth
yeah I mean that's that's the kind of
God that we serve yeah in fact if we
look a lair in Matthew 6 verse 19 says
do not lay up for yourselves treasure on
earth where moth and rust destroy and
where thieves break in and steal but lay
up for yourselves treasure in heaven
where neither moth nor rust destroys and
where thieves do not break in and steal
for where your treasure is there your
heart will be awesome so I think given
that Jesus wasn't talking about living
large Jesus was talking about providing
for your gonna god will provide your
needs yeah somewhere it says your food
and water will be sure right yeah it's
an Isaiah well you know what's
interesting about this sort of whole
pandemic that's that's getting out there
you kind of realize what you need and
what you don't know and I think that was
kind of a thing when I when I was
walking through all those homes after
the tornado and just seeing house upon
house upon rubble I mean they are now in
the process of just taking all the
contents and throwing it out on the
ground and you just see like all this
stuff is just stuff right you can come
and it can go and then as we talked with
people and prayed with people the
biggest thing that they were saying was
we're just so glad we
we didn't get hurt no there's people I
mean that's what's really important in
life so yeah we don't have to guess what
Jesus was talking about because he
actually has a whole list earlier on in
Chapter six as you were saying Keith
verse 25 sums it up really there is more
to life than material things but Jesus
sees that there's some importance to
certain material things and he's more
than willing to provide it for us but it
needs if it's done in the correct order
the answer is yes we can leave a
physical legacy as well as a spiritual
so that was awesome when I was doing
this study so there is a visual that I
found that fits this perfectly I'll
never forget it's really awesome
Michelle what do you see I see
coins quarters mm-hmm it's like a
plastic egg and a phone and a phone yes
the phone is opened to a timer the more
experienced people at the table can
correct me but I've found that there are
really two things in life that wait for
no man and that is time and opportunity
yeah so some people understand this and
they spend all their time chasing
opportunity or they use every
opportunity to maximize their time but
they're also trying to maintain or
juggle their spirituality right um but
for the Christian however this shouldn't
they should have different priorities
Michelle was right we have some corners
here we have a plastic egg and we have a
phone that's set to ten seconds each
item represents something so we have
these coins they're gonna represent our
physical legacy the things that we want
or want to attain so education money
homes whatever whatever the case then we
have this egg the egg represents our
spirituality
more specifically God and God being for
the Christian should be the center of
our lives
right and then we have the phone well
the phone is set to ten seconds that
represents a life span or just the time
we're here on earth ten seconds okay
because could be gone in a flash so key
this is what I need you to do so
when we're looking at this egg here
representing God God says putting me
first and I will supply all of your
needs so Keith what I needed to do is
take your hand and have the egg in the
palm of your hand like this
your dominant hand probably a fairy so
then we have these quarters that
represent everything that you want to
attain you can put it closer to you here
so you have ten seconds your life span
to try to pick up as many of the
quarters as possible without moving the
egg from the palm of your hand
you ready yeah ready set go
assuming I can only use the one hand yes
done oh okay
so count how much money did you get
there's a dollar seventy-five a dollar
seventy-five rich man well so as I said
before the Christians should have
different priorities God needs to stay
at the center and when we allow him to
provide for us we will forever be amazed
right he will guide us to - on what to
do and when to do it
so as the Christian relies on God and
keeps him at the center he will provide
how about you open up the egg and see
what's inside oh yeah that's what I was
thinking so which would you prefer you
know what I want or that dollar 70 class
awesome thank you thank you
so yeah the Bible says reminder Matthew
6:33 that all these things shall be
added unto you if you put God first and
his righteousness and we're reminded in
Isaiah 55 verses 8 & 9
that's God's thoughts and his ways are
higher than anything we could ever
imagine
has it's been your experience you know
putting God first has he's provided for
all of your needs yeah
time after time I've just seen God come
through right at the last minute man
like any time I need something I'm
stressing over bills or just whatever
thinking something's not gonna be
provided right at the last minute God
comes in and that it's just to the point
now where I just don't stress I'm just
like God's got us covered and you know
my wife sometimes has a little harder
time but she's seen it over and over -
and so she our faith just gets built
every time but that's what marriage is
about you know balance so where she's
kind of like you need to be worried
about this and what God's got us you
know I've I've seen it happen but this
kind of reminded me of a picture I've
seen of a of Jesus with a big old teddy
bear behind his back everything they
don't everyone I was back and a little
girl has a teddy bear and he's like we
give it all to me and she's like going
on to it like she wants it but he's got
something way better behind his back you
know yeah you know I think that it's
it's one of those things that takes
pressure off of you there's a lot of
things that are out of our control you
know as you can tell I mean a pandemic
can quickly change your existence but
when you kind of have that that
perspective that you know you've got the
king of the universe on your side and
you know like when the disciples were in
the boat with Jesus you know like
they're freaking out but they're right
next to Jesus like sleeping right you
know Devine and Jesus is like you know
why would you guys be scared because you
know do you really think God's gonna
like let me die you know the closest
they're the safest place to be is next
to him and so I think that that you know
when when you give Jesus that Shepherd
role in your life he's gonna lead the
flock to food and water that's what he
he needs to do he's gonna give you what
you need
well except my closing point here oh so
it can feel like a lot of pressure to
live up to God's expectations and to
develop this spiritual legacy that we
should be focusing on and sometimes
things do happen they're outside of our
control like this tornado that caused so
much damage it was the scary experience
but
because of previous training we know
what to do and we did our best the best
that we could to stay as safe as
possible and we're all here today praise
God I believe that the same should be
applied to our spirituality every day we
should be doing all we can to develop
not just not just to really be focusing
on our spiritual legacy per se but our
connection with God each day we should
do all we can the best we can and to do
what's right with the help of Jesus with
the help of Jesus Christ
practice makes a prepared person once
you agree it's not necessarily perfect
but it makes a prepared person for you
to do the best that you can
Jesus lived the life in close connection
with God which allowed him to leave us
his spiritual legacy that we can pattern
ourselves ourselves after and when Jesus
went back to heaven he said we could do
the same with the help of the Holy
Spirit and it's the Holy Spirit's job to
comfort us to teach us and to guide us
and you can find that in 1st John
chapter 14 verse 26 so some people came
to mind some biblical characters that
were developing their spiritual legacy
think of Daniel Daniel was rich he had
status he had a bunch of contacts being
an official in the government but what
it what is one of the things that he's
most remembered for besides prophecy
what story comes to mind we think about
Stan's good lines done to never
compromise on his faith even you know
faced with death exactly and also his
diet this was an unexpected situation I
mean he was captured brought into the
king's palace and now there's a bunch of
food in front of you that you know it's
just against what God's will is it would
have been so easy to rationalize mm-hmm
okay this is a unique situation I'm
taken out of my country I'm now a slave
I might as well just you know adhere to
it but that was really neat that he
stood up and and even when he was asking
for the pulse you know what what did the
the servant tell him like no way you
know the king I'll have my head if I do
that but he was still bold enough to be
like just just let me try it you know
you'll see and and God honored that and
it was easy for him because he had
purposed in his heart previously that he
wouldn't defile himself
that's the key I think with anything in
life we can't change these random
circumstances that come up but in
preparation if you if you had built your
faith and your you know way of reacting
to something off of something prior to
that disaster you're gonna you're gonna
treat it totally different yeah and he
was living a lifestyle it's kind of like
a habit for him it was nothing new to
stick to principle were you gonna say
something keep it yeah I just think it
misses where you know I guess the faith
and works rubber meets the road you know
there's an action that comes with it
it's like the military you know they
don't just tell you now you need to be a
good soldier read this book yes no you
in order to be a soldier we're gonna put
to you through drills we're gonna put
you through as close of a circumstance
as we can possibly put you over and over
and over again so that when it happens
you react and you react the right way
you react the way that we've trained you
and that's why it's supposed to be in
the Christian life as well I remember
you know when it was in grade school in
Southern California we used to you know
get her under our desks for a earthquake
drill you probably remember doing that
yeah remember this so it's like you know
you were preparing for that disaster so
that when it happened you knew exactly
what to do even as a kid and I remember
having earthquakes while in school and
having to do those things and we knew
what to do because we were we were
trained to do it right so it's the same
way in the Christian walk you know if if
you are going to be successful you have
the train and your training is involved
in many things it's it's in reading the
Bible it's praying it's you know more
than reading the Bible but trying to put
that scripture to memory it's doing
those things that you've read about and
putting them in action over and over and
over again so that it's like muscle
memory you know so that if for example
like you're a little kid and your
brother hits you well you don't hit him
back you know we're working on that one
else we are at my house to where so
we're working on that but
but the whole point is training to be
like Jesus what about joke in the book
of Job before all of his wealth is
listed
what does job chapter 1 verse 1 say he
was devoted perfect upright you know it
says he eschewed evil he feared God all
these spiritual legacy is being built
before we even get to the materialistic
but he was prepared we know he was
prepared because by the time everything
happens you see his training come out in
his action because the Bible says in all
this which is a lot of bad stuff that
just happened
it says he sent not Abigail also came to
mind she had status as the wife of a
rich person a rich man but she's known
as a peacemaker exactly Abigail David
had an army that was with him and they
were super hungry and so he went to send
message to the wealthy person that Abel
yeah yeah his name means fool and so it
was like no way and he was partying and
he was all drunk and so while he was you
know hung over in the morning
Abigail went and prepared a whole meal
for David and then gave you know the
food to him but David when he when he
got the message that a neighbor wasn't
gonna give him food he was gonna wipe
him out yeah and so it was because of
his wife's actions praise God for godly
wives right I mean sometimes we we act
the fool and and you know the wife has
to step up and that's one of those
stories and then it was with it and I
don't think it was the same day I think
it was within a week or so maybe two
weeks Mabel died of a heart attack and
then Abigail became David's wife mm-hmm
that was before he was king - yeah
before he was King so yeah guys yeah
maybe he was being seduced by part of
his wife because he was be reacted but
in the correct way right away
Noah is another person I think of when
it comes to like training and
preparedness you know yes
especially in the faith context he is
told that something's gonna happen that
is seems completely ludicrous but he
faithfully he just day after day he does
what God says he makes a pattern of
following God following God following
God following up 120 years later it's
time to get in the boat he's been
preparing to get in that vote by
building it you know one stroke of the
hammer at a time he gets in the boat
yeah in the face of ridicule like the
amount of time like thinking God is this
ever gonna happen like everything's in
God's timing right I was just thinking
about another like Abraham and Sarah
their kid they're like God's never gonna
do it let's do it our own way you know
we gotta we gotta trust in God's
promises and his timing is really good
story to Moses was like when you got
told him to leave that Israel I don't
know thank you
mm-hmm but he was scared but you got
told him you know I'll be with you yeah
those are let's put him through the
wringer yeah I think you know also that
training that Moses had it early on in
his life to the point where even God was
frustrated with the people in my own
wife mouths Moses like know that I do
that you know I think that training and
that that Moses had he understood the
big picture that God was trying to get
at you know and so when the children of
Israel were literally against Moses he
was still able to to say I have your
greater good at heart in there you know
try to keep him on track as in all
things the best example we have is Jesus
even from a little child you know all
those all as much of the Bible as they
could put in his head you know the
scriptures that they that they had he
was learning those things and he was
preparing his life after that pattern so
that when he it came time for him to be
the Lamb that was slain you know he was
ready he was made ready by the pattern
of his life he spent you know 30 years
preparing and then three and a half
years
yeah acting out that thirty years of
preparation you went above and beyond
beyond in the end he didn't just do the
right thing as a sacrifice he acts that
those people who were beating on him to
be forgiven mm-hmm it's incredible so
with all of these examples that you
realize that you can live your legacy
before you leave it that's really the
most important thing actually those
people that we mentioned were living
their legacy before we even found out
that they left one right most people you
hear about their legacy after they die
no you know it's like what was it the
doctor who advocated hand-washing just
like one of the most important medical
discoveries and but during his time he
was ridiculed they said that the more
blood that was on their outfits was a
sign and a status symbol of look at how
many people I've cut open yeah and so
you can imagine the just filth that
these guys would go into if you were a
good doctor you were dirty because you
you you had opened up tons of people and
so yeah that concept came across people
were like upset at him they were calling
him a heretic and like he was like let's
just wash your hands yeah a lot of times
though I guess that's what we uphold is
maybe the most impressive examples of
legacy are people you realize they have
a legacy before they die mmm you know
you think of people like dr. King you
know he had a legacy before he passed
away you think of people like George
Washington you know he had a legacy
before he passed away Abraham Lincoln
different people throughout history you
know they make an impact they have a
legacy before they pass away and
hopefully in each one of our homes
especially you know those of us who have
children we're leaving a legacy before
that time comes I read an article with
Steve Jobs wife that she said that it
was her sole mission in life to give
away all the money that they had created
for Apple and that her children would
not inherit that money that was really
interesting because I don't know you
know what what Steve Johnny was Buddhist
you know I don't think he really had
that kind of a Christian perspective but
I thought that was really interesting
that his wife was making mention that
she wanted to like literally not pass
that wealth on to their kids you know as
a kid you probably like what but you
know I think they probably realize money
corrupts yeah yeah and you know it does
make sense
you don't die and then all of a sudden
you get millions of dollars to leave to
your kids no you got to work for it
throughout your lifetime so it's the
same way with our spirituality it
doesn't happen after we die we have to
live it so we can leave it and it was
just encouraging that it's it's a
day-by-day thing just take it one day at
a time and it's our connection with
Christ that allows him to develop a
spiritual legacy within us and it takes
a little bit of the pressure off to work
hand in hand with Christ it's getting
off of the throne no no Jesus on the
throne man well we hope you enjoyed this
episode for us here a part of our
spiritual legacy that we're trying to
leave is with the show aleem see live
and for a friend of mine she goes to her
church's community center every single
Sunday just to help out so the point of
this show is to have real conversations
and also to hear what you have to say so
please answer this question in the
comment section down below
what does leaving a spiritual legacy in
your life look like and someone else
could read your comment and get a great
idea of how they of what they can do on
their side of the world so we're looking
forward to reading through the comments
and interacting with you guys once again
we thank you so much for your support
and we will see you guys next week on
LED live by
[Music]